that's fine but y'all know what I'm
talking about you know what I mean I
understand what you're kind of where you
were going with that it's a I know you
were it's an old I didn't understand I
know that I debate a lot yeah
say what you need to say I've heard it
all before to be honest and hey you know
going back to my personal story because
everyone's telling me how I feel and my
unlikelihood you know that's fine I know
who I am as a person I know who I am as
a woman I'm glad you did and I just
don't want to participate in that I've
made mistakes in the past again like I
said not here to judge anyone or shame
anyone
um but I do believe your value does not
come from body count or lack of Body
Count
Your value for me comes from a higher
purpose ma'am and I'm not trying to
sound too sexual but body count does
matter because of the Wall Street the
value does go down it matters to you as
well yeah you only have one body for a
reason and that's why you're refraining
from sex yeah so it matters yes or no
you're judging a Woman by the amount
penis is that is that in her vagina what
about what about us judging you the
amount of times
I don't you don't why does everybody
want to [__] Chris Brown we know he's
[__] a lot right you know he probably
has an STD here we're not going out
probably I mean what do a lot of women
want to [__] Chris Brown
dude really I don't know they do he's
really skinny I don't know you might not
want to but I bet you he's not liking no
[__]
also I don't think they're judging him
off of how many women
yeah you're a virgin on your wedding day
you have an 80 chance of a happy
marriage if you if you're a virgin on
your wedding day you have an 80 chance
of a happy marriage if you slept with
more than five people it's just a 25 so
it matters
are you know and I can't I can't tell
the man what his standards are for if he
wants a woman with a look like they said
I don't really care about a man's body
count I mean at the end of the day if
we're getting married you know like
let's let bygones be bygones but I can't
be mad at a man for you know not wanting
a woman with the body count over 10 or 5
I think for us like like definitely one
body is good like men like that right
but the the point is that you're you're
saying that you gave it up to one person
but this person might have to wait x
amount of time can you explain why why
is it that men are judging a Woman based
on how many penises enter her vagina
please tell me it's unattractive why
what it it just is like what does do you
think it just stretches out and it's
just it's never gonna shrink back
I'm educated like I I know that a
woman's vagina Okay then if you're
educated experience why are you not
attracted to a woman that has I don't
know 30 body counts I feel like I like
her experience I do like the experience
and the skills that she's bringing to
the bed
I would like the experience for me to be
the next number but commitment no
because why would 30 other people let's
say the body count is 30 right 30 is is
decently high right
why as number 31 would I fully commit to
something that but probably 26 of that
those 30 bodies didn't have to commit to
because the
no but I think at the end of the day it
kind of comes down to men feel like
women have to do more to have sex like
we have to like I feel like in their
brains we have to like open our legs and
like
is that how you feel the point is we
like exclusivity why would we want some
somebody that everybody else has had
right and I feel like we're emotionally
attached
the liberty of having all the women that
you want then you can't have like the
woman who comes the guy that you have to
teach in bed like come on I do I'm
actually like a good learning experience
okay this is Cap this is cat no but and
that's all my friends I'm actually a
cougar so I actually like teaching boys
what to do because I want them to learn
what I like let me finish second and the
second reason why is because men
historically had to ensure paternity so
they didn't like a girl that slept
around because they didn't know if
they're passing on resources that's
theirs and you still see this issue
today that men are raising kids that
aren't theirs like there's a um a DNA
and that's very Noble there is a DNA
testing center no it's Noble if they
know but a lot of men don't know where
they said one out of four came back
negative and so they don't want to hoe
because she's a lot she's less likely to
be loyal what now a hoe oh Lord I don't
know what she was saying uh there is
statistics that like show that if you
the more body count you have the you can
see that the the divorce rate is higher
based off what number she's at so
there's like there's statistics to kind
of back it up or moving in with a man or
a woman before you get married the odds
of you getting married to that person it
goes down dramatically yeah I just
learned that one recently actually so
that's why again I do not live with the
man you know I don't plan on doing that
my opinion on that out on the whole
divorce rate with five or more I'd
listen this is this is what I believe my
belief that maybe you know because in my
case I have had multiple partners but I
know what I'm looking for and what in a
man that I want Americans I do want
marriage so if I know what I'm looking
for and I like what's up here it doesn't
matter like I might actually I think
maybe I'll stay again this is all
hypothetical I don't know I have a
strong feeling that I would stay with
this man
for life because I know what I'm looking
for I know what I've already experienced
and I have no desire to go finding
something else unless we agree on
polyamory then what I'm too I'm too
selfish for that but I mean in regards
to like sexual encounters too like you
kind of brought up like yo no one wants
a virgin a bed I think that's a great
learning experience like a great time
honestly to enjoy with your partner
um and you know after you get married
you feel like oh man she's a virgin she
doesn't have any experience good I am
excited because you have the whole
marriage to explore I was talking about
as a woman men want virgins women don't
okay
I want to address a comment it says I
don't mind it personally MJ says a woman
that has multiple sex partners is
looking for the next sex partner and not
a husband I would like to address that
I'm actually looking for a husband same
and I have had multiple times you have
multiple right now what do you mean sex
partners yeah what's your body
I don't know if I want to say that
because I don't want to judge what's
your body count you have you don't you
don't want to hear mine you have
multiple sex partners right now
uh yes right now okay I wish I was you
because I can't say that I gotta wait
till I get back to Brazil so imagine
this what are you talking about I don't
even understand what you're saying why
can't you I said you have multiple sex
parties right now meaning like you're
with me I'm dating I'm dating I'm going
around and seeing who I match with
because I'm looking for a partner for
life so multiple is at least four right
no two that's not multiple dancers
that's a pair okay okay continue so to
me multi means more than one means more
I agree with you okay so the question so
the question can you come back to the
question can you can someone expand can
I ask you real quick all right hold on
one second so it says a woman that has
multiple sex partners is looking for the
next sex partner not a husband I want to
address that because as she said we both
agree we are looking for our husband now
she's currently not in sexual relations
I am and so I want to address them and
say yes I am looking for a husband I'm
not looking for my next sex partner how
could you be looking for a husband while
having sex with two dudes as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible